[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture
bush nathalie wolf patrice carmouze
on va parler d'art contemporain
peut-être de l'autre art contemporain
avec notre invité benjamin olivennes
bonjour et merci pour elle merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes vous êtes dorment à
niveau est agrégé de philo vous
enseigner à l'université de columbia
vous préparez aussi votre finissez votre
thèse c'est à dire à new york et vous
êtes d'ailleurs en direct avec nous de
new york je crois qu'il est à peu près
très tôt pour que merci beaucoup de vous
être levée pour nous et pour parler de
votre livre l'autre archontes au point
qui est publié chez grasset qui est un
essai très documenté très très heureux
dit je vais citer peut-être la première
phrase de de votre livre dans les salles
de vente dans les foires d'art
contemporain dans certains musées d'art
moderne triomphe des artistes dont tout
le monde sait qu'ils n'ont aucun intérêt
et voulzy très plus loin quelques noms
ceux de jeff koons de damien hirst
d'anish kapoor ou encore de maurizio
catalano ou des français comme claude
lévêque morlaix ou ubu rennes alors on
va alors ça c'est la première partie on
verra parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses dans votre essai mais peut-être
la première question avant d'aller plus
loin
pourquoi votre sens le marché des grands
collectionneurs mais aussi des
institutions publiques qui dépendent du
ministère culture ont privilégié un
arbre vous dites vous qu'il est la
plupart du temps à signifiant moche ou
provocateur pour une raison très simple
et disons le le traumatisme des grands
avant garde de la fin du 19e siècle
début du 20e siècle puisqu'il est très
connu et même répétées envers le temps
que les bourgeois de cette époque-là on
rit des impressionnistes de courbet de
man
un de van gogh qui n'ont pas compris le
travail de van gogh de sézanne plus tard
de picasso et que pourtant et c'est ces
artistes et et d'immenses d'artistes qui
ont élargi qui ont renouvelé et élargi
la notion de la beauté et qu'en plus ce
qui avait eu l'intelligence de
comprendre cela on fait des profits
faramineux donc les îles ont l'ailé en
raison de ce traumatisme originel
les gens du monde de l'art aujourd'hui
ils ne veulent surtout pas rater le
prochain jean gogh et donc tout ce qui
leur apparaît comme subversif des
apparemment déplaisant et
incompréhensible ils le prennent ses
qualités ses défauts là ils le prennent
comme des qualités des signes et fait
qu'il s'agit d'un nouveau van gogh et
qu' il y a le groupe profite à se faire
et dans les faits deux réalisent de gros
profits des justement alors et vous
venez d'évoquer la question de la beauté
il ya en effet deux éléments qui sont
vraiment importants dans votre
démonstration donc le premier sur la
beauté la recherche de l'harmonie qui a
longtemps été le but se donner les
artistes alors pourquoi selon vous la
recette il coupe et de la beauté il
recherche aujourd'hui dites-vous plus la
provocation on l'a dit à l'instant et
qu'est-ce qui explique tout de même que
le succès de cet art qui ne s'accomplit
plus uniquement dans la recherche du
beau il y aurait beaucoup de choses à
dison la roue au cours du 19ème et 20ème
siècles à a incorporé en lui une forme
de deux très grands artistes ont réussi
à donner une beauté et la laideur je
pense par exemple aux démons de goya
ovivo l'égard de rembrandt ou non de
velazquez on a les artistes ont élargi
la notion de la beauté en la faisant
parfois naître dans l'horrible mais
surtout on a cru que la beauté des
cuisines et du passé qu'elle avait été
congédié et ça c'est notamment c'est
ainsi que les jantes interpréter le
travail du fiancé derco t il et de
beauté était subjective et est relative
justement c'est de ces traumatismes dont
j'avais parlé avec lui et donc les les
gens ne savaient pas ce qu'était la
beauté et donc on pouvait s'en passer on
peut s'en passer parce qu'elle n'existe
pas qu'elle est subjectif qui est une
invention du regardeur et non dans le
tableau or ce n'est pas du tout vrai que
la pause est un besoin humain que nous
continuions de la chercher partout dans
notre vie
et si cet art cet art vous dit
contemporain du succès je crois que
c'est pas un succès réel je sais pas
s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui achètent
des cartes postales de ses oeuvres d'art
contemporain pour les mettre dans leur
chambre d'étudiant paraît par exemple ça
ça me paraît un critère de réussite
autrement plus réel que celui des prix
dans les salles de vente un instant t
j'en viens à votre deuxième proposition
de votre essai c'est qu'il existe donc
un autre art contemporain vous le titre
d'ailleurs de votre livre qui est
méconnu ignoré des foires des marchés
des institutions et vous mettez
d'ailleurs en avant certains artistes et
on va reparler dans un instant alors si
l'on vous suit bien cet autre art
contemporain
il est très inspirée d'un art français
qui donne notamment une peinture assez
humbles assez rigoureuses qui a dominé
le monde jusqu'à la deuxième guerre et
qui serait aujourd'hui passé sous
silence c'est bien ça oui et je me
concentre spécifiquement sur le cas
français
mais ce n'est pas tout car contemporain
il existe pas dans le monde
déjà il existe un autre xxème siècle que
quelques uns des artistes qui enfin au
20e siècle les peintures souvent
figurative de très grande qualité et qui
n'allait pas dans la sens de la marche
immédiate de l'histoire de l'art et
qu'ils ont cet autre xxème siècle
désormais il a émergé après s'il ya des
gens comme hopper un peintre comme
bodnar qui était vu pendant des années
comme une charte d'impressionnistes
tardif est un peintre bourgeois pin pon
dépeinte comme les chaînes freud ou
bacon angleterre sept autres 20e siècle
et connu mais il met ses peintres sont
vus comme des individualités
ddd espèce de pot mais sympathique dans
le xxème siècle alors qu'en fait ils
constituent une histoire qui sont
reconnus entre eux ils sont connus ils
se sont regardés et cette histoire s'est
prolongée en france
en fait j'en suis la trace à partir de
balthus et giacometti qui sont les deux
derniers grands artistes dits figuratif
ayant travaillé en france ayant une
gloire mondiale et balthus giacometti
ont eu des amis des disciples qui ont
été de grands artistes qui ont été
suivis par des cadres des critiques des
poètes d'aider des photographes comme
cartier bresson qui avait connu la
génération d'avant et qui ont suivi
cette la génération suivante
allez on se pince qui s'appelle sam
szafran qui fait la couverture de mon
livre et ensuite je suis le fil jusqu'à
nos jours en fait c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça que je fait émerger cette autre
art contemporain ce n'est pas sûr me
faut non seulement je ma subjectivité et
mon goût mais en ce moment sur une
histoire réelle de la reconnaissance des
artistes entre eux justement faire un
peu l'avocat me dire parce que vous
pourrez quand même de subjectivité je
reprends votre critique de l'art de ce
que vous appelez l'art contemporain
officielle c'est-à-dire des scouts ses
compagnies dont vous dites est
insignifiant qui relèvent de
l'escroquerie parfois de la clownerie
pourquoi pas mais là c'est quand même
votre subjectivité et qui parle moi je
pourrais aussi vous répondre qu après
tout c'est serait dont vous parlez est
un excellent pas mais je pourrais vous
dire que je trouve ça assez ennuyeuse
zaffran de vous parler bon il a pas que
des escaliers son atelier c'est un
très bon article peut être pas un grand
artiste que finalement je préfère les
hommes de françois morlet que que celle
de hopper qui me donne un peu le cafard
je veux dire par là on est au mes
affirmations contre affirmations
est ce que pour dire les choses
autrement est ce que vous pensez qu'il
ya un bon goût un mauvais goût et qui on
décide ont coûté bonne question
il ya évidemment une part de
subjectivité que je revendique c'est un
livre bien écrit à la première personne
qui est personnel et et qu'ils jugent
espère inviter les lecteurs eux-mêmes à
s'engager ou à réagir de manière
passionnée et pourtant je me suis rendu
compte en observant l'histoire de l'arc
que malgré tout il y avait une forme
d'objectivité
c'est des choses qui s'imposaient c'est
plus facile à dire non par les artistes
du passé c'est à dire que velasquez
vermeer rant consensus sur bien sûr les
ça si je parle des étudiants vous taxez
les piliers du temple mais disons sur
eux le consensus se fait et autour d'eux
le le consensus peut se faire et je
crois que artistes dont je parle
le le consensus peut se faire avec le
temps les pendaisons très profonde c'est
que ce sont des créateurs de forme
originale c'est à dire qu'il vous montre
le monde d'une manière qui n'appartient
qu'à eux et si vous regardez beaucoup de
tableaux de de safran au coût de
sécheresse à lédenon vous avez parlé
ensuite vous groupe
si vous accompagnons dans votre vie vous
verrez un escalier vous penserez un
safran ou vers un ciel vous penserez un
sécheresse c'est vrai qu'on doit noyer
ou de la même façon après avoir
rencontré un gars
alors ça c'est vrai et vous verrez de
même que vous rirez les scènes nocturnes
vous pouvez penser à des new yorkais je
peux penser à des auteurs et les
artistes que je critique a contrario il
me sens qu il ne crée pas de forme qui
vous il ne crée pas de forme ils
reproduisent des formes déjà existantes
d'associer dans lequel nous vivons et on
pense rarement à ces artistes disons
après avoir vu une exposition de ils ne
se sont pas des gens qui vous
accompagnent dans la vie je me permet de
croire qu'il ya une objectivité dans ma
subjectivité mais bien sûr c'est
subjectif
oui il ya eu une des choses également
vous vous dénoncez dans votre ouvrage
c'est le mythe du progrès d'histoire de
l'or c'est à dire une histoire de l'art
vie comme une flèche à sens unique
orienté vers un but final on serait
passé du figuratif à l'abstrait or il me
semble que l'art abstrait et l'art
figuratif peuvent coexister quand même
et sur un autre plan on peut dire que la
peinture figurative continue d'exister
quand bien même par exemple la
photographie a fait son entrée dans
l'art
on voit bien que certains peintres
figuratifs utilise aussi la photographie
à l'appui de leurs oeuvres
alors tout ça ça pose au fond est bien
la question de la définition de l'art
contemporain
finalement qu'est ce que c'est pour vous
est-ce que c'est l'oeuvre des artistes
qui vivent dans la même époque nous
est-ce que lorqu'il temps pour un c'est
l'art qui utilisent les moyens
technologiques du moment finalement
qu'est-ce que c'est l'art contemporain
l'art contemporain 10 ans et y ait une
expression toute faite et qui est l'art
contemporain qui officielle en fait ce
qui est d'un triomphe en salles de
ventes que les institutions publiques
exposé au château de versailles sur la
place vendôme avec ce terrain et puis il
ya tous l'art contemporain c'est toute
la création artistique qui se fait à
notre époque est celle ci elle est très
vaste parce que le l'art l'art
correspond à des des tendances profondes
de l'être humain et des dénés besoin de
l'âme humaine donc de la bande des six
des séries télévisées des chansons tous
à partie vous savez de la création
artistiques ou artisanales contemporaine
et donc si on élargit cette cette
perspective si on incorpore toutes les
manifestations de la créativité humaine
le l'art contemporain c'est beaucoup de
choses
et ça ça peut évidemment c'est toujours
lié aux technologies en présence par
exemple je sais pas si elle sait des
musiciens ils font de la musique et les
ordinateurs ou de l'électronique
il ne faisait pas ça il ya cent ans et
en même temps il est beau à voir des
progrès technologiques les avancements
technologiques
il ya des les vieux moyen des moyens
traditionnels qui reste toujours
pertinents à notre époque est de même
pour la musique est toujours pertinent
de faire de la musique avec une guitare
et un micro de même il est il est
toujours pertinent de peindre avec un
pinceau des deux lui la toile ça
n'empêche que malgré le fait qu'il
existe d'autres moyens technologiques et
que ces moyens technologiques peuvent
donner de résultat artistique très
intéressant oui c'est vrai que un moment
donné on a pu penser que la peinture et
étendard dépassée elle existe encore
aujourd'hui je reviens justement à ce
figuratif et abstrait vous parlez de
mandrillon et et vous rappeler en effet
que ces mondrian il ya des oeuvres
figuratives et d'ailleurs il il a
continué pendant toute sa vie à faire du
figuratif et de l'abstrait
en même temps vous avez raison de
rappeler ça mais s'il est connu au
mondrian aujourd'hui sideci reste dans
l'histoire de la ces comme père de
l'abstraction c'est pas pour ses oeuvres
figuratives
je veux dire par là est ce que
finalement si des artistes que vous
n'aimez pas enfin que vous reprochez qui
vous reprocher d'être des représentants
de l'art contemporain officiel est ce
que ces artistes rennes n'ont pas amené
justement une rupture est ce que c'est
pas ça aussi d'histoire de l'art c'est
la rupture qui arrive alors que certains
artistes que que vous défendez et qui
sont remarquables
ils sont fous que les continuateurs de
ce qu'il faisait se faisait avant oui
vous avez entièrement raison
le mais je suis frappé de ce qu avec le
temps
ce qui nous apparaissait comme les
ruptures les plus importantes du xxème
siècle reprennent leur place et qui
d'autre chose réémerge vous ai parlé de
bonnart par exemple l'oeuvre de bonnart
a réémergé au cours des 20 à 30
dernières années alors qu'elle
apparaissait comme complètement dépassé
par rapport à des ruptures envoyé comme
un impressionniste tardy jose 10 et est
donc avec le temps la dimension de
rupture historique compte bien sûr mais
moins que la qualité des oeuvres et ce
qui est et ce qui reste évidemment
mondrian reste comme l'un des fondateurs
de l'abstraction l'abstraction et une
rupture très importante du 20e siècle et
elle a donné des résultats prodigieux il
ya de très belles et très grande
peinture abstraite mais par exemple le
musée marmottan à paris a exposé il ya
un an et demi le brillant pour monter en
figuratif et son affection exceptionnel
parce que la peinture figurative
mondrian d'avant 1900 7,8 ses
prodigieuses et le tient aujourd'hui
c'est certain oui alors justement on va
parler de cet autre art contemporain
vous avez mis en lumière un certain
nombre d'artistes safran qu'on a cité
tout à l'heure à riga desmazières
sécheresse on l'a dit mon fleurs et
certains d'entre eux comme safran ont
comme à ricains sont quand même assez
célèbre très connue des professionnels
des galeristes également un petit peu du
grand public
certains sont décédés d'autres sont très
jeunes est ce que vous pourriez nous
dire eh bien ce qui vous touche en eux
et pourquoi
voilà pourquoi veut pourquoi ils sont
les représentants de sept autres arts
contemporains que cette fois-ci vous
saluer alors je vous ai dit gg
j'ai suivi le fil de la tradition de la
tradition de la peinture en france par
exemple
safran les cas ils ont des amis
disciples
et balthus de giacometti ils ont été
très marqués par leur rencontre et
disons ils ont été aimé par des gens qui
avaient connu malthus et giacometti par
diego giacometti le frère d'alberto qui
a ému le créateur de meubles par des
critiques comme james love par des
poètes comme bonne foi par un
photographe dont cartier bresson part
des galeristes des marchands
donc ils sont ils se sont vus comme
appartenant à une tradition alors vous
dites qu'ils sont connus écoutez j'ai pu
aller dans un dîner aux lecteurs des
galeristes
c'est quand même connu par exemple oui
ces missionnaires
c'est pourtant sur mes articles n'ont
jamais eu s'affrontent mort à riga est
morte n'ont jamais eu une grande
rétrospective à beaubourg alors sont des
artistes qui y ont vécu en france
travailler en france et même dans des
grandes institutions françaises
arica été exposée au musée thyssen à
madrid en 2008 je croyais a jamais eu le
droit à une telle des expositions à
paris en france alors que ce serait très
méritée et ce qui me touche dans l'eure
dans l'horreur c'est le son des peintres
de la réalité ces actions des pinces qui
regarde le monde dans lequel on vit le
le monde le quotidien et qui essaye de
trouver la traduction graphiques et
plastiques par l'horreur par leur
travail ils sont attentifs à l'ordinaire
on sai s'inscrivent dans le réfectoire
vous venez dans l'histoire de la radio
française c'est des enfants de courbet
de gare de sézanne et ils sont
conscients de ce qui c'était tout ce qui
s'est passé au xxème siècle des ruptures
et mais il pense que la peinture dite
figurative encore des choses à dire est
qu'elle peut nous apprendre à voir le
monde une nouvelle manière d'une manière
qui n'est cave de même que
même que oui oui le fera si compte
beaucoup pour moi qui est celle de
baudelaire le génie c'est de créer
inventif voyez quand nous disons d'une
initiation qu'elle kafkaïenne on utilise
fait référence à un concile créé par
quatre cas et je pense que ces artistes
là on chacun d'argent créé les poncifs
dire qu'on ne voit plus le monde comme
avant après après les avoir vus alors
j'aime bien cet essai qui encore une
fois très érudit très très très fouillée
vous êtes beaucoup lu notamment il ya
vous parlez beaucoup de gens clair
notamment un qui causa la fluence et
pire il ya un galeriste il me semble qui
vous influencent beaucoup c'est claude
bernard je crois qu'à peu près tous les
artistes de chez claude bernard vous
trouve grâce à vos yeux
mais il ya d'autre au fond il ya
d'autres galeristes qu'il faudra
travailler intéressant j'ai je pense à
perrotin qui explose actuellement
jacquard qui est plutôt on pourrait dire
un figuratif il ya templon qui appose
viala le support surface c'est quand
même quelque chose à un mouvement
intéressant est ce que est ce que ces
gars là ne trouve pas grâce à vos yeux
et est ce que c'est peut-être parce
qu'il travaille aussi appelé les
américains n'ont pas du tout j'aurais du
mal à ne pas aimer les américains je vis
aux états unis et je m'intéresse à la
peinture américaine et y compris à des
peintres qu'on ne voit jamais en france
comme d'hab comme un un abstrait
abstrait et figuratif de la côte ouest
fait dix bonnes cordes
un autre américain expert films porteurs
que sont des peintres absolument inconnu
en france et très talentueux alors les
artistes les articles et de claude
bernard
effectivement les ont déserté la
génération d'avant 1945 dont je parle
sont beaucoup passé par claude bernard
désolé je parle de quatre artistes
exposés
c'est pas tous les artistes qu'il a
exposé ce ne sont pas que des artistes
qu'il a exposée mais effectivement il a
été pour moi un des porte flambeau de
l'art que j'aime il a exposé d'aiken en
france ce sage et pas de problème et les
autres galeriste oui sans doute mais
vous savez qu'on vous dit il explosé
dans le figuratif cfc pas figuratif
françois qui m'intéressent faire
comparaître figurent on peut être
apparemment figure à ce défi et ne pas
forcément être très intéressant je sais
pas pour les nuls les jeux via là ça
m'intéresse chacun y jacquet jacques
hébert dont jacques est intéressant
c'est pas mal
[Rires]
et alors on a un autre philosophe luc
ferry qui lui non plus n'aime pas
beaucoup l'art pourtant courant et
qu'ils fussent elles oui officielle au
social qui rappelle que les premiers
monochrome sont dus à des gens comme un
pôle bio alphonse allais qui se
revendiquait comme fumiste le premier
monochrome d'aller quêter rouge
s'appelait la récolte de la tomate par
des cardinaux apoplectique sur les bords
de la mer rouge où ferry conclu en
disant que ce que cela faisait avec
humour et bien d'autres de malevitch à
soulage et bien lors et recyclés dans le
registre du pontifiant vous êtes aussi
radical que lui dans votre critique
[Musique]
disons que tout cas c'est fait par
rapport à cette petite de leurs
contemporains que je veux j'ai mûri j'ai
essayé aussi de parler des choses que
j'aimais dans mon lit tout au long du
xxème siècle et jusqu'à aujourd'hui et
les monochromes
oui c'est à dire qu'effectivement les
routes d incohérent inventé les
monochromes et le ready-made 20 ans ou
30 ans avant le l'abstraction et du
chant cela dit j'en ferais pas un absolu
effectivement donné du monochrome
cela dit j'aime bien
la 560 j'ai vraiment beaucoup kg 2 et
malevitch fossiles dont le je suis assez
je suis je suis ouvert à tout faire à
tous et pas sectaires mais je trouve
quand même que ce qu'il ya de plus
marquants pouvoir dans la peinture du
20e siècle
c'est les pins dont je parle c'est
tradition cette tradition de l'autre 20e
siècle et de l'autre à contemporain
celle de hopper de balle cuche
giacometti de lucian freud de morandi de
bonnart et jusqu'à nos jours à safran
sécheresse pour terminer mes deux
petites questions je voulais vous poser
vous parliez tout à l'heure justement de
ces bourgeois qui avait raté les
mouvements importants de la peinture qui
voulaient pas les rater aujourd'hui mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de barbie
d'aider des collectionneurs d'art
contemporain et cours d'eau leurs le
fait qu'ils font ça par passion peu plus
surtout pas que par goût de l'argent
il ya beaucoup de capitaines d'industrie
justement où luc ferry aussi vite dit ça
au fond il ya peut-être un lien avec
leur goût de l'innovation destructrice
qui rend obsolète qui était avant est ce
que vous pensez que c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles de beaucoup de
ses capés de l'industrie en dehors des
évidemment des moyens qu'ils possèdent
sont des fans des passionnés d'art
contemporain officiel justement oui
c'est si je savais pas qu'il avait dix à
lui créé mais c'est ça me paraît assez
juge ce qui me paraît juste aussi c'est
que l'art l'art contemporain et dans la
filiation de deux traditions qui se
disent quand le loup pop c'est le fait
de sortir des objets de la société
consommation et de les proposer en tant
que tel à l'admiration des gens donc ça
c'est la fameuse soupe de de warhol
importe qui oscille au changement de la
de l'urinoir de duchamp donc le pop et
le conceptuel sénart de l'idée est
peut-être qu'il ya effectivement dans le
pigeon les grands mots dans le
capitalisme
une sympathique
cuillère pour le pop et le conceptuel
parce que c'est parce que c'était deux
l'art de la société de consommation de
la société marchande et du marketing et
de l'idée non peut-être qu'effectivement
il ya une sorte de d'acccord qui se fait
entre cette tare entre cet arrêt et le
capitalisme
et puis la dernière à la question
justement sur cette évolution de de
l'art contemporain est ce qui est ce que
vous pensez qu'il ya un moment où on va
trop loin on le voit un peu peut-être
plus plus facilement avec ce qu'on
appelle la musique contemporaine en
impression qu elle est à l'aise dans un
mur et qu'on revient pas en arrière
est-ce que vous pensez que des arts
plastiques peuvent être guettés par sept
par cette même tendance
oui un retour d'ailleurs de la peinture
et même du figuratif dans le dans les
galeries dans les écoles d'art dans les
expositions
c'est évident puisqu'il une sorte
d'essoufflement ou d'épuisement des
autres avant garde d'humanisme
conceptuel d'ailleurs même on pourrait
me dire que les artistes contemporains
le les pubs les plus chères aujourd'hui
ce sont des figuratif c'est jeff koons
on pourrait dire c'est un figuratif et
c'est donc il ya un retour bien
d'épuisement rien essoufflement mais
j'espère que ce retour de la peinture
vassal et se nourrit au aux meilleures
sources de l'art du passé par exemple à
vélez wahaha rembrandt
oui pour parce que ce qui m'inquiète en
fait c'est peut-être la perte de l'oeil
est incomplète du monde de l'art avec le
passé de l'art cercle plication été
fasciné par velasquez les artistes
contemporains d'aujourd'hui sont
fascinés par picasso et est ce que les
artistes de demain se connaîtront autre
chose que je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
dans les 20 dernières années c'est ça le
plus important pour moi je mange merci a
fait 10 morts
mondialement olivennes voilà donc votre
motivation votre livre s'appelle l'autre
art contemporain vrais artistes et
fausses valeurs c'est chez grasset c'est
à dire qu'il faut laisser encore une
fois érudit avaya beaucoup de beaucoup
de connaissances dans votre
beaucoup travaillent donc c'est un livre
assez court mais très dense et avec le
caennais après on peut être d'accord sur
certains points pas forcément surtout
parce que c'est ça qui est ça qui est
formidable débat le métier merci
beaucoup
[Musique]